THURSDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITMENT COMMITTEE --
WE ALMOST HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS
FOR A QUORUM SO AT THIS TIME WE
ARE GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE HOW WE TYPICALLY DO
WAIT FOR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
TO COME BUT WE WILL BE HOLDING
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ANYONE TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE AND I BELIEVE THESE.
TWO ITEMS ARE RELATIVELY NON
CONTROVERSIAL SO LET'S HEAR
FIRST FROM MISTER STONE.
FILE ITEM TO A. B..
THIRTY SIXTY SIX THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS A. B.
THIRTY SIXTY SIX IS A FARM BILL
TO A BILL THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED LAST YEAR
AND THE GOVERNOR VETOED THIS IS.
A BILL THAT TRIES TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD WITH RESPECT TO
MOBILE HOME [inaudible]
OWNERS AND THE THAT PARK OWNERS.
WHEN WE NEED TO ENFORCE THE
MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LA?
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NO
MECHANISM TO ENFORCE MOJO
RESIDENTS WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS WHO
ARE TYPICALLY LOW INCOME IN MY
DISTRICT MOBILE HOMES PROVIDE
SOME OF A SIGNIFICANT FORMS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
ARE FORCED TO HIRE AN ATTORNEY
WHICH THEY CAN'T AFFORD AND SO
THERE ARE LOTS OF ISSUES THAT
ULTIMATELY GOING RESOLVED.
SO THE THE BILL THAT WE PUT ON
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK LAST YEAR.
HAD THE FE H. BEING THE ONES
COLLECTING THE MONEY UNDER THIS
PROGRAM AND TRYING TO ENFORCE
THE MOBILE HOME PRESIDENCY LAW.
THAT WAS A PART THE GOVERNOR WAS
NOT HAPPY WITH SO WE WENT BACK
TO HIM AND HAVE NEGOTIATED.
A PROGRAM NOW WITH A CD WERE HDD
WILL COLLECT THE MONEY WILL TAKE
A REVIEW OF THE COMPLAINTS THAT
ARE FILED.
AND WILL THEN REFER OUT TO A
LOCAL LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDER
FOR THOSE ISSUES THAT ARE THE
MOST EGREGIOUS.
IT'S STILL ESSENTIALLY PILOT
PROGRAM IT SET UP SO THAT EIGHTY
WILL COLLECT THE MONEY FOR ABOUT
A YEAR AND A HALF.
IN ORDER.
TO FUND THIS SO THAT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE FUNDED OUT OF OTHER
FUNDS TO GO TO HTTP AND THEY'RE
ONLY OBLIGATED TO ENFORCE.
UP TO BE ABOUT OF MONEY
COLLECTED.
AFTER THE PERIOD OF TIME THAT
THIS.
LIKE ORGAN WHAT'S TO DO SOME OF
THINGS HOW EFFECTIVE PROGRAM IS
WHAT THE DEMAND IS BITING THE
BIGGEST ISSUE THAT THIS IS GOING
TO RESOLVE IS IT PROVIDES A
FORUM. FOR ENFORCING MOBILE HOME
PRESIDENCY LAW AND WILL
HOPEFULLY MAKE ALL PARTIES TAKE
THE VIOLATIONS OF THE EMERALD
VERY SERIOUSLY AND GIVE FOLKS A
FORM FOR THE MOST EGREGIOUS
ACTIONS.
THIS IS THE I THINK GOVERNMENT
IT'S AT ITS BEST TRY TO LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD.
AND GIVEN APPROPRIATE FORM WHERE
ONE IS NECESSARY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I DON'T
[inaudible]
RIGHT EYEWITNESSES.
HIGH ESPERANZA ROSS ON BEHALF OF
GSM WHILE THE GOLDEN STATE
MANUFACTURED HOMEOWNERS LAKE --
WERE HERE AND SUPPORT.
WE WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE FOR WORKING WITH BOTH THE
GOVERNOR AT GOVERNOR BROWN'S
ADMINISTRATION OVER THIS PAST
YEAR AND MORE RECENTLY WITH ONE
OF THE LARGEST PARK OWNER GROUPS.
IT AB THIRTY SIXTY SIX REFLECTS
THE COMPROMISE AN AGREEMENT WE
ASK YOUR CONSIDERATION THINK YOU.
MAY I ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
ROGER JOHNSON.
AND I AM A VETERAN THE ANIMAL
HOMEOWNER.
AND THE BEEN FOLLOWING A. B. --
THREE SIX SIX FROM ITS BEGINNING
LAST YEAR AS TWELVE SIXTY NINE
MYSELF MY NEIGHBORS WE ADVOCATE
TOGETHER.
AND WE REALLY NEED HELP.
WITH ISSUES THAT WE HAVE WITH.
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS --
SETTING THE TABLE --
SO THAT WE CAN ALL BEGIN TO TALK
AND RESOLVE THE PROBLEMS AND
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE WITH EACH
OTHER.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU LET ME
ASK IF THERE THE MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THAT'S GOOD OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS CATHARINE BORDER
THE WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE STILL IN
AND OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION WE UP REALIZE IT CAN
GET AMENDED AT THIS POINT BUT ON
WE HAD REQUESTED THAT THERE
WOULD BE THIRTY DAYS TO CORRECT
ANY EGREGIOUS VIOLATIONS BEFORE
WENT TO COURT --
THE BILL ONLY HAS TWENTY FIVE
AND THOSE FIVE DAYS MIGHT MEAN A
LOT FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES WHO CAN'T GET.
A CONTRACTOR OUT THERE OR
SOMEONE.
TO ALLEVIATE THE PROBLEM BEFORE
IT SENT TO YOU ON SENT TO THE
LEGAL PROCESS.
SO THAT'S STILL A CONCERN OF
OURS WE APPRECIATE THE TWENTY
FIVE THAT WAS NEGOTIATED BY THE
OTHER TRADE ASSOCIATION.
ON THE OTHER ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
IS WITH REGARD TO THE FEE.
AND THE FEE IS GOING TO BE
APPLIED TO ALL MOBILE HOME LOTS
IN OUR MOBILE HOME PARKS BUT
THIS PROGRAM ONLY APPLIES TO OF
SPACES THAT APPLY UNDER THE
MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LA.
WHICH THERE'S A THEIR BIG GAP
THERE SO IF WE HAVE PARK ON
RENTALS ARE VIEWS OR EVEN VACANT
LOTS WILL BE PAYING A FEE FOR
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE DON'T GET
ANY BENEFIT FROM --
AND I THINK.
LASTLY.
IF WE HAD BEEN AT THE TABLE. TO
HELP NEGOTIATE THIS WITH AGE CD
I THINK THAT WE WOULD OF TRIED
TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM WHERE ALL.
ALLEGED VIOLATIONS WOULD BE
ADDRESSED BY THE DEPARTMENT --
SOME OF THE SMALLER COMPLAINTS
ARE GOING TO BE GONE ERA CAN BE
I HEARD AND IT'S ONLY THE
EGREGIOUS COMPLAINTS ARE GOING
TO BE --
ACTED UPON BY AGE CITY SO WITH
ALL THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THE WISH TO POSE.
OKAY BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMITTEE DISCUSSION.
WITH THAT BACK TO THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THAT THE TWO MAJOR
GROUPS GETTING INPUT ALL ALONG
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR THEY
CD.
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES IN HERE I
THINK THAT WE WOULD.
ALL AGREE THE OPPONENTS AND THE
PROPONENTS THAT MAYBE COULD BE
BETTER BY.
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE HAPPY
ULTIMATELY WITH WITH THE RESULT
THAT WE HAVE IS A PILOT PROGRAM
WE WILL LEARN A LOT ABOUT HOW WE
COULD MORE OFFICIALLY ADMINISTER
IT.
I THINK OR EVERYBODY'S VERY OPEN
TO THAT AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL SO
THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD AND GET
THE PROGRAM IN PLACE GREAT THANK
YOU WE NOW I THINK OF ENOUGH
MEMBERS TO SUBSEQUENT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CHIU HERE TO HEAR MAIENSCHEIN.
MUNCHING HERE CHAU.
CHOI GLORIA.
GLORIA HERE AMONG.
WOULD [inaudible]
WHAT HERE [inaudible]
HER HER.
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER WE
CAN'T AMENDED AT THIS TIME THIS
IS A THIS IS SIMPLY --
I'D BE HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION THAT WE CONCUR IN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD IS OUR MOTION
[inaudible]
THEIR SECOND.
SO WE CAN'T ACTUALLY MAKE ANY
MEMBERS OR SOME DISCUSSION WITH
THE WITH SOME OF THE PARTIES
ABOUT A QUESTION OF ONE OF THE
DETAILS BUT WE ACTUALLY CAN'T
MAKE IT AMENDMENTS HERE.
BUT THE MOTION THAT WE WOULD --
IS TO CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS WHICH IS WHY
THIS COMMITTEES MAYBE.
AT LEAST THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN
TOLD BY STAFF [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WHY IT'S BEEN SO MOVED THEIR
SECOND [inaudible]
SURE ABOUT WITH THAT --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CHIU BY CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO CHAO. ONE HER HER
HER HER [inaudible]
JOEY [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE LEE MONTH
[inaudible]
WOULD.
WHEN I SAY WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN AND WITH THAT THANK YOU
MISTER STONE LET US GO TO OUR
SECOND FINAL ITEM FILE ITEM TO
A. B.?FIVE SIXTY FIVE MISTER
BLOOM IS HERE RIGHT ON TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON RIGHT.
CRADDICK IT TRAPS GET AFTER.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
OF THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO UPDATE
AND CLARIFY THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION OF LIVE WORK
UNITS.
THESE ARE UNITS THAT COMBINE
BOTH RESIDENTIAL AND
OCCUPATIONAL FUNCTIONS IN ONE
UNIT FREQUENTLY USED BY ARTISTS
AND ENTREPRENEURS.
THESE UNITS ARE SUSTAINABLE
HOUSING SOLUTION THAT ELIMINATES
THE NEED FOR COMMUTING.
REDUCES GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND HELPS TO CREATE.
DIVERSE LIVABLE COMMUNITIES.
ALTHOUGH THESE UNITS ARE ALLOWED
TO BE BUILT UNDER BOTH THE
BUILDING AND RESIDENTIAL CODES
THERE ARE AMIGUITIES.
IN BOTH AND THAT OFTEN RESULTS
IN CONFUSION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
ABOUT THE TYPES OF STRUCTURES
THAT ARE ALLOWED AND HOW THEY
MAY BE BUILT THIS CONFUSION CAN
DELAY.
OR HALT THE CONSTRUCTION OF
UNITS THAT ARE.
SO AB FIVE SIXTY FIVE* HCV
TO REVISIT AND CLARIFY PORTIONS
OF THE BUILDING CODE IN
RESIDENTIAL CODE THAT PERTAIN TO
LIVE WORK UNITS.
WHILE GIVING THE DEPARTMENT
BROUGHT FLEXIBILITY.
IN ACCOMPLISHING THAT TASK.
THAT'S MY PRESENTATION MY
WITNESS HAD A FAMILY EMERGENCY
AND SO IT'S JUST ME.
TARA HAPPEN ENTERTAIN QUESTIONS
WHICH I PROBABLY WON'T BE ABLE
TO ANSWER.
HER FIRST BEEN A MOTION WITH THE
BILLS ARE SECOND.
IS THERE ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC THAT SUPPORT THE BILL.
THAT OPPOSE THE BILL.
ANY QUESTIONS I'LL TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOSE THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
TO MOVE IT FORWARD IN THE SECOND
UNLESS THERE'S ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CHIU TYPES YOU AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN CUT IT CHAU.
CHOICE I GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE WE MONTH.
WOULD.
WAIT I THAT MEASURE IS OUT
UGANDA WITH THAT --
WE CAN [inaudible]
DO ADAMS.
ADD ONS FOR MISTER CHOI.
ASSEMBLY MARCELLI --
ON ITEM NUMBER CHIU A BE THREE
ZERO SIX THE VOTE IS THREE TWO
ONE AT THE MOMENT --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHARLIE NO.
OKAY --
BICU GHOSTING AND WAIT FOR THE
FINAL TWO MEMBERS AND AS SOON AS
THEY ARRIVE WE WILL.
TAKE THOSE WORDS AND THEN
ADJOURN
THAT ON MS IMAN
[inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY [inaudible]
BY [inaudible] FOR YOU.
I AND NUMBER --
TWO CEOS THE AMONG MANY
[inaudible]
I BUT FOR THE MOMENT I THANK YOU.
AND FOR MR CHAU [inaudible]
WHICH OUT.
ITEM NUMBER ONE EP [inaudible]
FIVE SIX FIVE I ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
FEELING [inaudible]
THEN [inaudible] ZERO I AM NEVER
GOING TO BE THESE [inaudible]
ZERO SIX SIX YEAH I THAT'S
REALLY SAD Y..
TODO.
OKAY SO WHY BOTH OF THOSE ITEMS
WROTE --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
AND AT THIS TIME THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED